SMIL alhamdulillah Salam alaikum peace
be with you today we're going to be
taking a look back in history and we're
going to show you how when Muslims ruled
a certain part of the world how they
were living in peace with Muslims Jews
Christians how they were at the pinnacle
of science of inventions of knowledge
how there was truly peace when the
Muslims ruled according to the divine
law that was sent down the Quran and the
authentic sayings traditions of the last
and final messenger said to mankind the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him it
was definitely a time well you didn't
have to lock your doors crime was almost
eradicated and so many other wonderful
things were going on but there was truly
peace so we come back here on the Deen
show we're gonna learn more about this
with dr. Gerald Dirk's would be right
back
sit tight this is the theme
this is the thing is the danger
peace be with you i Salam alaikum how
are you dr. Gerald Dirks
I am fine and peace be upon you brother
thank you for finding the time to be
with us here again on the Deen show my
pleasure now you have your own section
on the Deen show calm people can go
there to read about you to know about
you they can log-in WWD show calm we've
done several shows you have your own
personal section there alright today
we're gonna be talking about when
muslims ruled a part of the world and
the peace that came with that time can
we get into this topic and talk to us
about this please I think probably the
best example of this would be Muslim
Andalusia Andalusia yeah which you know
Andalusia refers to the Iberian
Peninsula yes or put today Spain and
Portugal and this was really a
remarkable period in the world's history
but before we journey into Muslim
Andalusia we probably ought to take a
step back and look at why there even was
a Muslim Andalusia because a lot of
people say Muslim Andalusia oh my
goodness there's Islam conquering by the
sword again yeah but we need to take a
look at the actual history of what was
involved at that point in time in the
Iberian Peninsula at that point in time
in the 600's and early 700 we had a
population that was comprised of Jews
Unitarian Christians and Trinitarian
Christians this is before the Muslims
yeah before the Muslims are even there
yes what was going on was that the Jews
were being persecuted by the Christians
because of their religious beliefs
okay so we got Jews being persecuted by
Christians right
that area of NLO Spain right we have
Trinitarian Christians and Unitarian
Christians persecuting each other okay
so this is a place of tremendous
religious strife who was the king there
at that time well the king was white tez
or with the what is ax yeah
was the king who was right before the
Muslims moved into Andalusia I heard
there was very high taxes crime was also
very rampid well I think the one thing I
want to focus on though is this
religious persecution yeah that people
were not free to practice their religion
they weren't okay no so in this cauldron
of religious persecution what happened
is that in the year 710 a Jewish
delegation was sent from the Iberian
Peninsula to North Africa a Christian
delegation was also set Unitarian
Christian delegation and they came to
the Muslim rulers in North Africa and
they said come into the Iberian
Peninsula you know we need you to come
in and take over as a result of this in
the year 711 a small Muslim army under
the command of Tariq Tariq even Zi odd
invaded what is today Spain now the key
thing to remember is as soon as they
landed they were immediately joined up
with by Jews and Unitarian Christians so
this was not simply a Muslim invasion
yes this was an allied assault by Jews
Unitarian Christians and Muslims all
fighting against a persecuting Christian
group now in fact one of the the
Christian rulers of
of Ceuta joined the Muslim alliance at
this time so you know this is brand this
is conquest by the sword is really
misleading this is a myth to it well
certainly there was fighting but it's a
myth to say that the Muslim simply came
in of their own initiative and took over
they were asked to come in by the
indigenous population because they knew
that under the Muslims under Islam there
is guaranteed freedom of religion can
you force someone by the sword to become
a Muslim no absolutely that's absolutely
against Islam absolutely against Islam
were told in the second chapter of the
Quran let there be no compulsion in
religion period this is a flat absolute
statement so know as a Muslim I am not
allowed to try to force someone to
become a Muslim absolutely not yeah as a
Muslim in fact I bear the responsibility
of guaranteeing someone else's freedom
of religion as I have to do yeah to live
up to the Quran so the Jews and the
Unitarian Christians in the Iberian
Peninsula very definitely one of the
Muslims to come in because then they
would have freedom of religion so this
sort of sets the stage and 711 Muslims
did invade and by 714 they had almost
all of the Iberian Peninsula under their
control so how was it now Muslims come
in was there havoc was it hell well what
happened was the Iberian Peninsula if it
entered its Golden Age Golden Age Golden
Age so that's antithesis now of havoc in
hell I mean Oh made you tell them I like
more like heaven on earth well you know
the rest of Europe is looking at the
Dark Ages okay but the meantime and in
Muslim Andalusia we're seeing never
before seen progress in agriculture in
architecture in literature in science
the Greek classics are being studied in
Muslim Andalusia in fact this is this is
an interesting thing if you go to
college today and you take a course in
played out
and you read you know Plato's works
you're reading an English translation of
a Greek translation of an Arabic
translation of the Greek original Wow
because these Greek works were preserved
in Arabic and that was really about the
only place they were preserved let's
take a break hold on off Daniel we'll be
right back with more on the Deen show
whatever Allah commands you to do you
need to do it this land has tolerance
and mercy and compassion to know that
Allah you know will forgive you as long
as you do what you need to do as long as
you turn back to him Islam is a system
of mercy and compassion and it is for
the best benefit of all of the people
that surround it Muslim and non-muslim
back here on the Dean show with dr.
Gerald Dirk's we're talking about the
golden ages you said it
yes heaven on earth oh well I don't
think we can classify anything is heaven
on nothing can compared to the bear that
the delights that are waiting the
Paradise and of receiving when you when
you do God's will and you live a
righteous life and then God gives you
His mercy and grace and you get that
paradise but it was a good time it was
overall peace Oh compared to the rest of
the things are going us yeah it was
tremendous I mean here you had
universities operating you had
intellectual advancement taking place
you had advancement in so many different
areas whereas the rest of Europe was
basically still in the dark ages now let
me ask you this was God's law according
to Islam implemented at that time in
Spain in many places it was yes and you
know we always have to acknowledge that
there's always exceptions yes you know
and that some individual may be the
exception but as a general rule yes
so we had freedom of religion yeah and
in fact about five years ago Harvey Cox
celebrated Christian theologian wrote a
short article in the Harvard Divinity
Bulletin in which he talked about Muslim
Andalusia and held it up as the shining
example of interfaith dialogue that this
was the crowning pinnacle of interfaith
dialogue amongst other things Cox talked
about what he calls the convivencia this
period of conversation going on and he
notes that Muslim scholars bearded
rabbis Christian priests and monks all
sit around a table together studying and
reading over old manuscripts under the
auspices of Bishop Raymond of Seville so
I mean this is one classic example you
know put together here your Jewish
rabbis your Muslim scholars you
Christian priests and monks they're all
sitting around this huge table jointly
studying mm-hm
you know this is where do we have this
really happening even today so you
mentioned that that at that time science
was really at its pinnacle also and tell
us now because a lot of time when you
mentioned religion and then people feel
the conflicts with science but when we
study here we see that there's no
persecution of scientists at that time
no no no just the opposite
you know Islam has always encouraged the
development of both religious knowledge
and secular knowledge has been a
champion of the sciences you had early
Muslims accurately figuring out the
circumference of the earth when most of
Europe was still convinced that the
earth was flat so science was always
been important in Islam another example
of this interfaith cohesion that we see
in Muslim into Lucia is under Abdul
Rahman the third the Khalifa ruler of
Muslim Andalusia between around 912 and
961 here's a the ruler of Muslim
Andalusia and he goes and appoints açaí
eben Shapira a Jewish rabbi to be his
foreign minister so again we see this
interfaith working together that is
taking place in Muslim into Lucia far
cry from what we often seen today there
are examples Dante's Divine Comedy
heavily influenced Harvey Cox would
argue by Arabic sources that were from
Andalusia and one of the most famous of
Christian mystics st. John of the Cross
according to Cox heavily influenced in
Andalusia by Muslim mysticism
so we have this cross talk going on with
some influence taking place perhaps one
of the most exciting examples of that is
to turn to Cordoba the city of Cordoba
and Muslim Andalusia in the first half
of the 12th century and we have two
giants intellectual Giants living in
Cordoba at the same time one of them is
Maimonides probably the most famous
Jewish rabbi of the Middle Ages and also
living at the same time have been ruined
Muslim scholar scientist thinker known
in the West is avarice but it been
rusted these two giants intellectual
Giants living in Cordoba at the same
time have been rushing nine years older
than Maimonides and if we look at
Maimonides 13-point creative judaism
which orthodox judaism to this day says
this is what you have to believe in to
be a Jew we can look at these thirteen
points and see how they were heavily
influenced by urban Russians prior
8-point creed of islam so we have this
cross talk this cross influence going on
where with respectful interfaith
dialogue Jews are pushing Christians and
Muslims to refine their thinking
Christians are pushing Jews and Muslims
to refine their thinking Muslims are
pushing Christians and Jews to refine
their thinking and all of it being done
in a collegial way you know not a debate
- bam bam I'm going to score points on
you but a general advancement of
religious knowledge as well as
scientific knowledge so there's a
healthy dialogue going on a very healthy
and how are the rest of the delay people
how are they functioning in society is
there justice for all as sorry are they
safe yes they are they're saying
again there are always exceptions but
yeah it's a general rule it was a period
of great safety it was a period of
wealth compared to the rest of Europe
much higher standard of living than the
rest of Europe again the rest of
Europe's and the Dark Ages but here we
have huge universities being built huge
libraries being built and all of this
available to the people whether they
need you christian or muslim wow this is
amazing we're gonna take a break and we
right back with more you're on the dean
show do you think these things are going
to bring you happiness
you know why you keep going back to the
club and you keep going back to these
desires because you never find
satisfaction it's going to end up
causing you if it hasn't already a lot
of pain what we are offering in Islam
what we have found in Islam for
ourselves is a means by which our hearts
are in peace they're at rest they're not
discontent we are pleased with what we
have
those back here on the Dean show and
we're talking to dr. Jared Dirk's and
we're given a great example from history
when Islam was implemented that there
was justice that there was peace that
Jews Christians and Muslims were having
healthy dialogue they were collaborating
science was at his pinnacle other people
you had mentioned were in darkness yeah
throughout Europe talk to us a little
bit about this yes throughout Europe
this was the Dark Ages this was a period
where knowledge was being lost not
gained it was a period of of losing
intellectual knowledge not advancing
intellectual knowledge but Muslim
Andalusia was it was very different and
continued that way for several centuries
though eventually under what's called
the Reconquista of the recon kurung is
you know various Christian kingdoms
Castillo Aragon Lyon etc beginning to
push the Muslims back primarily because
the Muslims began to fragment yeah and
establish their own little petty 5 times
as opposed to remaining a unified force
and so finally by the late 1400s
you know the Muslims were practically
driven out of the Iberian Peninsula and
the Spanish under Ferdinand and Isabella
instituted the Spanish Inquisition which
is probably one of the history's great
examples of the horrors of religious
intolerance yeah you know it's Jews and
Muslims were systematically tortured in
an effort to make them convert to
Christianity or systematically killed if
they didn't this was terrorism oh
absolutely
but highest lanser state-sponsored yeah
state-sponsored terrorism
we're told that between somewhere
between 100,000 and 170,000 Jews refused
to convert and in 1492 by proclamation
of foreign
Izabella any Jew who did not convert to
Christianity was expelled from Spain so
this left a hundred thousand to a
hundred and seventy thousand Jews in the
Iberian Peninsula that simply had to
leave buu so what do they do how did
they manage to survive the answer is the
Sultan Bayezid the second who is the
Sultan the ruler of the Ottoman Empire
Muslim II Kingdom sent his naval fleet
under the command of Admiral Kemal rice
to evacuate the oppressed Jews and
Muslims another Muslims are sending
their fleet to go and help the Jews yeah
to evacuate the Jews from Spain variant
and resettle them in North Africa and
Turkey etc and give them places to stay
food and shelter yes yes yes Muslims are
doing this absolutely Muslims are doing
Wow in fact you know the Sultan is
quoted as saying they meaning Ferdinand
and Isabella impoverished their Kingdom
and enriched mine referring to the Jews
who left Spain and came to live in the
Ottoman Empire and in the Ottoman Empire
they were granted religious freedom
which they didn't have in Christian
Spain and they were granted limited
self-government which they certainly
didn't have in Christian Spain mm-hmm so
there was always amongst them the Jews
or Christians living under Muslim rule
there was justice there was dialogue
healthy dialogue and people weren't now
scared of their life or being you know
cut by the sword right exactly exactly
that you know especially for the Jews
was a great point of religious freedom
you know it's unfortunate that we tend
to look at Jewish Muslim relationships
only through the prism of the last 60 70
years mm-hmm and we fail to see that up
until that time we have this century's
long history of working together yeah
where Muslims were rather consistently
befriending Jews yeah
granting them religious freedom etc that
they did not have in Christian countries
why do you think now in the last few
minutes that we have there's a
sensationalism that's created you know
and there's just hype in the media that
you know Islam is coming Islam is gonna
get you and if it comes that's it all
your freedom everything that you no good
you have is going to be gone and they
create this fear frenzy and the people
why do you think this is well it sells
so business sure it sells you sell
newspapers this way you sell magazines
this way you so advertising on TV
because your TV ratings are going up
because you're giving a sensational
story you know it's the old thing dog
bites Ben you're not gonna put it on the
news man bites dog we'd give a headline
yeah you know we turn on your local news
what headlines it is fires and auto
crashes and you know murder and mayhem
because this sells unfortunately you
know the Golden Age doesn't sell yeah
and how important was that Golden Age I
mean is crucial Harvey Cox going back to
that article I referred to earlier
looking down the road after the end of
Muslim Spain looks it's Miguel de
Cervantes's classic book Don Quixote and
sees Don Quixote as being a nostalgic
wish to recapture what was lost with the
fall of Muslim Andalusia this is Spain's
greatest literary work and nostalgic
wish for the return of what was lost
when Muslim Andalusia fell Wow amazing
this is very enlightening thank you
again for being with us and if somebody
wants to get a hold of you to have you
come down to get your books to invite
you for a lecture how can they do that
they can go to my website which is
Dirk's online books com Dirk's online
books all one word thank you very much
my pleasure brother towards you - yes
thank you and thank you for sitting
through another episode of the Deen show
continue to tune in every week to learn
more about the Muslims to learn more
more about Islam and you can also catch
our new radio show at the Deen show.com
blog section and we hope to see you
again next time
same time same channel until then peace
be unto you